un bureau de vote à ciel ouvert pour des
électeurs riverains vous avez peut-être
vu si vous vous baladez dans le 20e
arrondissement un isoloir volant est une
petite boîte qui fait office d'urnes
l'association sauvons le bois de
belleville innove
devant l'échec des manifestations ou
autre pétition à la non choisi cette
voie référendaire le but questionner les
habitants du quartier sur l'avenir de
cet emplacement
doit-on y aménager un espace vert où
comme le souhaite la mairie réaliser un
programme immobilier
ce sera aux habitants de donner leur
avis oui je vois tout est fait voler par
rapport à oui c'est vrai que là bas
c'est très beau avec ça reste ça
continue à rester vert en même temps on
voit ça nulle tous âges tout ça bien
qu'ils veulent construire je dire aussi
parce que la vie là on aura plus rien ce
ne sera pas très joli malgré les arbres
ça me fera pas
sharp a aussi aussi jolie que le square
qu'on a un peu plus bas l'objet de
pareille mobilisation ce terrain qui
d'après les plans prévisionnels de 1982
aurait dû servir de prolongement au
jardin belleville un immeuble de six
étages comportant du logement social est
déjà en cours de construction mais sans
empiéter selon la régie immobilière de
la ville de paris sur les 5000 mètres
carrés de cet îlot de verdure plantés
dans un océan béton tout à fait d'accord
pour qu'il y ait de logements sociaux
pour qu'il y ait des constructions à la
condition naturellement que ça soit pas
à côté du lieu dans lequel vous habitez
en réalité il n'ya pas plus de
construction qu'ils en étaient prévenus
à l'origine il y a une surface des
espaces verts qui sera supérieure à
celle qui était primitivement prévu les
gens n'apprécient pas tellement on les a
pas du tout consulter la mairie fait
valoir de son côté les résultats d'une
enquête publique réalisé l'an dernier
une enquête publique tout le monde peut
venir tous ceux qui le souhaitent
c'est prévu par voie d'affichage dans
les journaux ça montre qu'il n'y avait
pas beaucoup de problèmes puisque
justement alors que tout le monde était
prévenu
seul un très faible nombre s'est
manifestée une mobilisation tardive qui
nourrit peu d'illusions il n'empêchera
pas quelle que soit l'issue du
référendum
la poursuite des travaux